well the 21 senators on the Judiciary
Committee will meet at 9:30 Eastern time
this morning they will likely vote along
party lines to send Cavanaugh's
nomination to the full Senate what
happens then is still uncertain Kika
senators from both parties are undecided
and if Republicans lose more than one
GOP vote they will need help from
Democrats ed O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill
with the next step for this nomination
Ede good morning good morning bianna as
you said the Senate Judiciary Committee
votes this morning and it could be a
largely symbolic vote because win or
losing committee he's going to the full
Senate Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell expected to call procedural
votes as early as Saturday morning with
a final vote by Tuesday that means a
high-stakes weekend of lobbying members
of both parties as you said Republicans
need to shore up support among their own
Republican senators Susan Collins Lisa
Murkowski
and Jeff Flake are all undecided and
could tip the balance against the
Kavanagh nomination the three met last
night with Democrat Joe Manchin of West
Virginia he is one of the three
Democrats up for reelection this year in
states that President Trump won by
double digits in 2016 they're facing
millions of dollars in ads back home
telling them they should vote for judge
Kavanaugh
at this point high-stakes lobbying
continues among those making calls
former president george w bush has been
in touch with Manchin and with some
Republican senators in recent days one
other interesting note in that
closed-door meeting last night among
Republicans the prosecutor who
questioned dr. Ford Rachel Mitchell told
them that if this were a criminal case
she wouldn't have enough evidence to
prosecute John and thank you